wir wollen jetzt mit der mama seiner
tochter sprechen mit der mama seiner
anna ermakova nämlich mit angela
ermakova die uns zugeschaltet ist größte
sie herzlich freie mal kommen guten tag
wir haben gerade über unsere gefühlswelt
hier gesprochene in der runde was
empfinden sie nach diesem urteil dass
uns erst mal total erschrocken hat also
erst mal mit gefühl scham oder trauer
traurigkeit und
wirkt ich war schockiert und sehr
traurig und
mitgefühl und frage mich wie kann ich
ihm helfen und
habe natürlich versucht ihm positive
gedanken zu schicken damit er sich
besser fühlt
was bedeutet jetzt dieser schuldspruch
für ihn für sein leben gerade hier in
der runde war schon großer optimismus es
gibt ja auch ein leben danach der der
wird wieder zurückkehren der wird sich
daraus kämpfen wie sehen sie das was
bedeutet dieser schuldspruch und diese
erhebliche strafe jetzt diese knast
strafe für ihn für das leben von boris
becker
persönlich bin ich der meinung dass er
zu hart verurteilt
es gibt viele menschen die
betrügen die verletzliche menschen
betrügen
leichtgläubige menschen die nicht
verurteilt werden oder die weniger
schwere strafen antreten müssen in
diesem fall ging es darum dass er
viereinhalb millionen von jemandem
genommen hat und aber dachte dass er
zehn millionen damit verdienen könnte
davon war überzeugt und die bank hatte
dem auch zugestimmt
und sein plan a nicht funktioniert
und so hat sich das problem dann sehr
schnell verschlimmert und den weg seines
den lauf seines ganzen lebens verändert
aber die aktuelle situation ist doch so
dieses urteil
bestraft auch seinen jungen sohn der
erst zwölf ist und komplett
unschuldigkeit kein verbrechen begangen
der ist gerade auf dem weg in die
pubertät kommt jetzt erst in eine neue
schule der wechsel von der ersten in die
zweite schule muss sich jetzt neue
freunde suchen oder braucht seinen vater
in dieser besonderen zeit seines lebens
besonders wenn die komplette englische
presse über ihn berichtet und das mit
zwölf jahren das geht doch nicht und er
muss das alles
verarbeiten und er ist ein kleiner junge
der seinen vater braucht er hat
überhaupt keine großeltern
die sind alle tot der vater von boris
gestorben und er ist ganz allein in
london
er muss das jetzt alles alleine durch
machen emotional finanziell er braucht
unterstützer
ist eine extrem schwierige zeit für
das kind hat doch kein verbrechen verübt
und soll doch nicht bestraft werden auf
diese gemeine art und weise für die
fehler des vaters ja das wird der teil
dessen sein den man sich möglicherweise
selbst als papa als vater niemals
verzeiht dass man seinem sohn seinen
kindern seiner tochter sagen muss ich
bin in den knast gekommen ich bin
schuldig gesprochen werden worden also
das ist der teil der kinder und
gleichzeitig gibt es noch eine mama dazu
elvira die die ganze zeit immer an der
seite von boris becker war früher bei
seinen tennis matches gab es nicht den
moment dass elvira nicht mit auf der
tribüne saß mit im publikum saß angela
ermakova die leitung steht gerade wieder
lassen sie uns in der runde darüber
sprechen aber jetzt sehe ich sie wieder
freier koffer wunderbar und jetzt
wackelt glaube ich das bild noch leicht
sonst diskutieren wir in der runde mit
wolfgang bosbach hat sich sie frau
ermakova also die mama elvira sie sind
selber mama wie muss die mama diese
momente dieser schuldspruch diese strafe
erleben frau ermakova wie muss die mama
diese so wahnsinnig harten moment
erleben
ich denke dass das extrem schwierig für
boris mutter ist
hallo
denn als mutter
bringt man ein kinder auf diese welt da
hätte sich zufrieden
und der schmerz des kindes
ist auch immer der schmerz der mutter
und dieser schmerz erfolgt ein nachdem
man das kind in die welt gebracht hat
und das muss einfach wahnsinnig
schwierig verlierer sein
und ich denke an sie wir reparieren
gerade nochmal die leitungen diskutieren
weiter mit wolfgang bosbach und patricia
riekel die weiterhin bei uns sind wir
sprechen über die rolle der kinder
gerade mit angela ermakova und die rolle
der mama und die ganz simple frage die
uns hier umgetrieben hat in den
vergangenen stunden wie sagst du so was
dein kind das muss ja ein brutaler
moment seien gerade bei kindern frau
rieke die das halt schon voll kapieren
natürlich also mit zwölf jahren mitten
drin ja also ich habe natürlich mit dem
amadeus habe ich natürlich mit leid aber
ehrlich gesagt das hätten sich die
börsen ein bisschen früher überlegen
können also so unschuldig und harmlos
ist das nicht was er gemacht hat wie
fremdkörper sagt also ich meine er hat
es ging es geht hier um millionen und
wie gesagt wozu er verurteilt worden ist
das ja nur die spitze des eisberges und
vor 20 jahren auch schon mal verurteilt
da muss man doch daraus was lernen und
ich glaube aber dass kindern mit der
situation trotzdem fertig werden und das
kommt jetzt darauf an wie seine mutter
wie lilly und wie die oma wie die damit
umgehen und außerdem
boris hat etwas geschafft seine ex
frauen verstehen sich untereinander
relativ gut und die können sie sich
jetzt auch um den amadeus kümmern der
hat zwei halbbrüder hat eine
halbschwester und
soviel ich weiss treffen sie sich auch
manchmal
und ich glaube dass es sich auch
vielleicht jetzt gegenseitig finanziell
unterstützen müssen denn etwas darüber
noch gar nicht gesprochen
es sind ja alle zum großen teil abhängig
von boris und seinem geld gewesen so ich
nehme an ohr den ich jetzt hier gerade
sicher ist als maler schon erfolgreich
der brauchte unterstützung nicht mehr
aber die der amadeus der brauchte zeit
sein der seine brüder seine halbbrüder
und und auch die frauen die um boris
herum sind und das ist eine ziemlich
geschlossene gruppe und da hatte einfach
glück gehabt auch mit den tollen frauen
also ob das ziel ist oder ob das die
barbara ist wie weit man kommt in diesem
system eigentlich los ist weiß ich nicht
aber die frauen halten zusammen und ich
sehen sich auch gleich wie heute geben
die frage sind sie da teilt dieses
kreises wie in frau riekel gerade
beschreibt verkäufer also erhalten sie
untereinander ganz engen kontakt all die
frauen von boris becker samt mama
vielleicht sogar
darüber sollte ich da habe ich nicht
reden das ist eine information die ich
privat halten will dann
fragen kann ich jetzt leider nicht bahn
lassen uns die bremer koffer lassen sie
uns kurz noch drüber sprechen wie konnte
das überhaupt dazu kommen also in dem
prozess ging es immer wieder darum ist
er jetzt ruhig der boris becker oder hat
er sich das nicht auch selbst
eingebrockt was glauben sie also wie
konnte es dazu kommen lag das auch an
arroganz einer großspurigkeit an
möglicherweise gutgläubigkeit von boris
becker wie geht ihre erklärung
eissing muss ich denke dass er einfach
schlecht beraten wurde am anfang
hätte dieses darlehen niemals annehmen
solle hätte versuchen sollen den besitz
einfach zu verkaufen und hätte sein
sollen wie viel er daraus bekommen so
hätte er machen soll es war ein
schneeball effekt der immer schlimmer
geworden ist er angefangen zu rollen und
es einfach immer größer geworden
er hat dieses darlehen von 3,5 millionen
genommen und hat es abgesichert mit
einem besitz von dem er dafür seit 10
million millionen wert und das hätte er
nicht tun sollen hätte er den besitz
zuerst verkauft dann wäre doch nicht
passiert aber
die zinsen von 5 prozent waren das
problem über die jahre hat das
verschlimmert der zins was hat sich
verändert und der besitz konnte trotzdem
nicht verkauft werden und je gab es
einfach keine andere lösung mehr und
nichts anderes und das darlehen habe
sich dann und so musste er dann ich
bankrott erklären und den rest kennen
sie aber das gericht die staatsanwältin
hat ja immer wieder gesagt der mann hat
einen schlechten charakter es ging am
ende um arroganz und vor allen dingen
unehrlichkeit in diesem prozess ist frau
emma koffer ihnen gegenüber boris
arrogant gewesen und ehrlich gewesen
noch einmal
realität dass ich nicht über meine
persönliche beziehung mit boris sprecher
des reglements wenn ich das jetzt leider
nicht beantworten ich würde gerne bei
den fall sprechen
und ich weiß auch nur für das verurteilt
wurde und das weiß ich auch nur aus den
nachrichten aus der zeitung
und man kann sich keine meinung bilden
über dinge die man nur in der zeitung
liest und so habe ich das erfahren
so kenne ich aus meinem leben und
deswegen weiß ich es einfach nicht gehen
sie davon aus dass er gut klar kommen
wird im gefängnis
er wird ja
composites extremely tiefe gut und passt
ja natürlich es ist schwierig im
gefängnis er hat überhaupt keinen
kriminellen hintergrund
das einzige was er tun kann ist zu
versuchen an andere dinge denken
oder vielleicht andere schwere
irritationen in dem er war genauso wie
oft pilates ein anderer verbrechen der
auch im ersten weltkrieg im gefängnis
war in england rund es aber geschafft
hat
indem er immer positiv geblieben ist in
dem ihr die hoffnung hoch gehalten hat
er war sich sicher dass alle
schwierigkeiten überstehen könnte und
dass die sonne immer wieder aufgeht
und ja boris könnte steiner podcasts
hören oder ägypten bücher lesen in
seiner muttersprache deutsch
seine gedanken komplett leeren
und sich mit höheren sphären verbinden
sowie unterstützung da könnte er die
unterstützung herbekommen denn irgendwas
auf der welt gibt es immer das einem
hilft und es gibt immer auch schlimmere
dinge wenn ich als bäcker zurück denke
bekomme ich immer noch gänsehaut bei
diesen wimbledon momenten vor allen
dingen dort bei unbeschreiblichen
matches vor allen dingen eben auf dem
grünen rasen dort ein wirklicher tennis
held ein held kann er all das bleiben
frau ermakova kann boris becker ein held
möglicherweise ein nein ja ich glaube
schon er wird ein herr bleiben
er ist immer noch der jüngste den es
jemals gab kommt er hatte eine
erfolgreiche karriere im sport die man
nicht vergessen kann
und letzte frage frau erlag auf waren
also
glauben
würden sie ihm sagen wenn sie diesen
moment irgendwas mit auf den weg geben
könnten also was wünschen sie boris
becker für die nächste zeit
ich wünsche im gründchen zur community
centers und ich hoffe dass seine strafe
verkürzt wird oder dass es wie nicht
voll ab
das wünsche ich noch und ich würde ihm
sagen dass er stark
emotional und physisch seine stärke
aufrechterhalten muss denn dies ist eine
große herausforderung in seinem leben er
muss stark sein und strammstehen
wir danken ihnen herzlich für das
gespräch
danke ihnen für das gespräch
danke herzlich